let's begin with the second session
thanks dylan for
asking again and take it on
wait am i good to go
yeah please go ahead oh okay awesome
cool yeah um i mean thanks again thanks
for coming back to part two
yeah so we're going to sort of uh kick
off
where we left with part one
um
so if you remember from the first part
of the tutorial
we talked about these three challenges
uh you know exploration credit
assignment generalization um we saw how
to solve them on their own
we saw how to solve them in pairs
and now in this part we want to try to
solve them all
at the same time like in other words how
do we explore in systems where we have a
long horizon and do this while
generalizing across states okay
um
i want to briefly remind
why we care about this generalization
issue and the point here is we want to
be able to do rl in sort of high
dimensional continuous state spaces so
you know you can think of a setting
where like states are images from a
camera
so you know the state space is
intractably large
on its own but like just in supervised
learning we want to be able to use
modeling and pick some sort of
hypothesis class that will allow us to
generalize across states and maybe even
actions
now like okay if you think about if you
think back to the first part of the
tutorial
like for example in the contextual
bandit problem
there we were mostly using modeling to
uh or like using our hypothesis class
scriptdef to capture things like rewards
but when we come to the full rl setting
there are a few different ways that we
can approach modeling and function
approximation i'm going to go over these
um sort of ordered by how strong the
modeling assumption is
so
one approach which we actually already
saw like implicitly in some sense when
we worked with uh policy gradient
methods and the first part is you know
pick a restricted class of policies pi
so for example like policies that are
parameterized by neural nets like here
uh big pi would be our hypothesis class
um another approach is that we can use
what are called like value-based methods
and here
we're using a restricted class of
hypotheses script q
which is trying to model the value
functions in the mdp and this could mean
we want our class to be able to capture
all possible value functions or it could
maybe mean we're just trying to capture
the optimal value functions
um and lastly
um and i apologize for this confusion
with the terminology here is uh you know
what are called model based methods in
the literature
and the reason i say that is just
because all of these approaches involve
modeling in some sense but these are the
ones that people call model based
explicitly right this means our
hypothesis class is like some subset of
mdps so we're we're directly
parameterizing transition probabilities
and
you know
rewards
so like with all of these approaches
we like algorithms that can handle you
know general classes of hypotheses
be it like linear models or neural nets
so
now that we have our hypothesis class
you know
value functions
probabilities
i'll briefly restate the statistical
goal for this setting um
we're going to follow the same episodic
rl setup as in the first part of the
talk so i won't focus on this the
important point here will be that our
goal will to be achieve
either sample complexity
or regret that's polynomial in like the
horizon
and the target accuracy
but most importantly in the statistical
capacity of our function class script f
um and in doing this we're going to
typically make some assumption along the
lines of realizability that says well
the hypothesis class we're working with
is indeed powerful enough to like
represent say q functions or transition
probabilities
um and i mentioned statistical capacity
here
when i say statistical capacity i'm
thinking back to these complexity
measures we saw in part one like vc
dimension and rad and mocker complexity
so like for concreteness you can think
like comp script f this is the capacity
this could be like log cardinality of
the function class or finite classes or
it could be like the feature dimension d
if we're doing linear models
but the point is this is not explicitly
going to depend on the number of states
which will reflect the fact that we are
generalizing
sorry dylan oh yeah um and one question
about the previous slide maybe i should
have asked in the first sure so here
you're assuming that you can always
restart the system from some arbitrary
distribution of states at every period
oh i'm assuming that this initial state
distribution is fixed and is unknown to
us
okay but
would it be possible that there are many
systems where once you've altered them
you can't go back like you know like
once you've saved run in one episode
yeah you have to sort of like restart
maybe from a different distribution
because you affected it is that
something that's not captured by this
setting uh that's not captured by this
setting i guess i can say more about
that maybe at the end of the tutorial
some of the things we'll discuss are
actually pretty easy to extend to that
setup others
um
not so much i mean it depends on this it
depends on the exact style of guarantee
you're going for
okay thanks
okay
um yeah so to motivate some of the
approaches we're going to look at here i
want to kind of explain why achieving
these statistical learning style sample
complexity guarantees in the general rl
setting is difficult and this really
comes down to an issue called
distribution shift
okay
so
the idea behind this issue
is kind of easiest to explain if we
think about
what an idealized reinforcement learning
algorithm might look like and i've
written an example out here so let's
just go through this step by step so our
idealized rl algorithm
let's say
we have some policy we've computed
we're going to run it and we're going to
gather some data from the the
distribution script d that it induces
over you know like states and actions
um
using this data we've gathered we're
going to fit some hypothesis class or
fit a hypothesis which could be like
value functions or transition
probabilities
using the data set we've collected
then we're going to somehow update the
policy using this hypothesis right this
could be like taking the greedy policy
if we estimate q functions
we're gonna keep doing this and the hope
would be that our performance will
improve as we do this over time like we
get better at estimating things
but okay what's the issue here
i mean the issue is that like if we
think of supervised statistical learning
or if we think about like generalization
um this is something that tells us
when we fit this hypothesis class or
fitness hypothesis f hat this is going
to do a good job at predicting
on you know future data if we gather it
from the same distribution script d that
we used to collect our data set
but the problem is like
even though f-hat might be a good fit on
this distribution script d
we're gonna update the policy to pi t
plus one and
we might be completely useless at
guiding this policy once we update it
because for example pi t plus one it
could take a different action from pi t
just at the first step in our mdp like
in an episode and we might end up with a
in a totally new part of the state space
where we don't have any data so far
and if we're not careful
you know
like say we forget what we've seen we
might cycle and we might fail to improve
all right but there's a couple different
ways that we can address this issue
but the point is that this is an issue
of distributionship this is an issue
where i get some distribution i update
my policy the distribution changes
so how can we address distribution shift
um
one way we can look at this is to try to
somehow control what is the number of
like effective
state distributions that we can
encounter
like the idea here is
you know if i have a small number of
possible distributions
as long as my algorithm doesn't forget
what it's already seen it's going to
stop getting surprised by new
distributions eventually and we'll get
meaningful generalization so for example
like if we think back to this square cv
method we saw for contextual bandits in
the first part of the tutorial
here we were able to get a regret bound
scaled with the number of actions times
the like supervised learning complexity
for the function class we considered and
what was going on here was that the
number of possible actions for this
setting
which
you can kind of think is controlling the
number of effective distributions this
was small so like as long as i explore
enough the number of times my algorithms
get surprised is just going to be
proportional to the number of actions
and so this you know strongly requires
that the number of actions is small but
the nice thing was it wasn't placing any
assumption on like what my hypothesis
class looked like or what the context
distribution looks like
um but in general you know for this
style of reasoning to go through when we
go beyond h equals one we need to place
assumptions on the mdp we're looking at
like if we think back to this
exponentially large tree structured mdp
from the first part of the talk where we
have a reward at a single leaf here
there truly are like a to the h
different state distributions
and
that means we can get surprised many
times
okay
the other approach we can look at
which you might hope would acquire your
would you know place weaker assumptions
on the mdp you're looking at is to use
some kind of hypothesis class that
allows for extrapolation and
extrapolation here means you know once i
learned how the function behaves for
some part of the state space
um
hopefully this tells me how it will
behave for the rest so like if you think
back to this linear contextual bandit
problem where we have
words that are linear in some feature
map
we had this lin ucv algorithm which gets
proportional to the dimension of the
feature map which reflects that it's
generalizing across context and actions
and the reason for this is like because
the rewards are linear
once we see
you know once we get a good estimate for
the rewards along like a basis in d
dimensions we can extrapolate what
happens on new directions that we may
not have exactly seen before
and
yes the only issue with this is you know
potentially this is placing a strong
assumption on
what kinds of hypothesis classes will
support
um so we have these two approaches you
know bounding effective distributions
extrapolation
both of these are going to make
different assumptions on the mdp or the
hypothesis class we're working with and
there's many different specific
assumptions we can make to implement
either approach that will lead to
different algorithms and different
sample complexity guarantees
and so the way we're going to structure
the next portion of the talk is to
explain how these approaches kind of
come together to give
the current like statistical landscape
of rl
uh as we understand it so like what what
so we're gonna try to see like what are
all the different assumptions we can
make
and how do these relate to one another
most of the terms you know in this
diagram
you won't be familiar with yet
but we're going to walk through them one
by one and
kind of get a sense for how they work
and just to explain like what what do
these colors on this diagram mean uh
green here is indicating like sample
efficiency like this is some kind of
assumption that leads to sample
efficient learning guarantees
um and red means not sample efficient
right so like all of rl is not sample
efficient because they're you know we've
seen some bad examples already
um
in this in this figure like which of
these
boxes are driven by applications and the
main knowledge from applications that
will satisfy and which of those are more
like for theoretical convenience
uh i mean pretty much all of these are
things that have come out of the
theoretical community but like once we
go through some specific examples i can
you know try to give a sense for
how these relate to real applications
but i mean
i was actually going to touch on this at
the very end i mean there's definitely
room for uh you know
better incorporating kind of like real
world considerations into the models we
have but you know is it's an area of
research that's developing very quickly
right now
so yeah um so to start off
we've already seen tabular reinforcement
learning in the first part which is this
little bubble um so our starting point
is going to be to move out one step and
look at reinforcement learning with
linear function approximation in a
setting called low rank mdp
so
you know the setup here is we're going
to be working in a value based setting
which means i'm going to take my
hypothesis class to be a set of q
functions which we're generating script
q
and we're looking at yeah perhaps the
simplest value based setting which is
where all my q functions are linear in
some fixed d d-dimensional feature map
which we're calling feet
so
for this approach to make sense
uh you know
it seems natural that we should
have our hypothesis class somehow be
compatible with the underlying mdp and a
basic assumption we can make which
generalizes how we approach the
contextual bandit problem is
realizability
this is just saying this hypothesis
class script q
contains the optimal q function q star
for contextual bandits
we saw that
realizability was sufficient for sample
efficient learning and this lin ucb
method was able to get regret polynomial
in the feature dimension
but the interesting thing is that it
turns out for rl once you go to multiple
steps
this reasoning actually doesn't extend
immediately
and there's a fairly recent line of work
that shows if you only assume
realizability the optimal sample
complexity for this problem
is exponential in the future dimension
so uh like simple efficient learning is
not possible
and intuitively what's going on here is
okay on one hand you have this linear
structure which which lets us
extrapolate if we partially learn q star
but on the other hand uh you know once
you go to multi-step rl
somehow this isn't helpful unless you
have a mechanism to guide you toward
q-star to begin with
so there's a stronger assumption we can
place on the mdp
which will lead to sample efficient
learning
and this is called the low rank mdp
assumption and so this property is going
to say that our transition probabilities
emit a low fat rank factorization with
respect to this feature map feed that
we're using to define our hypothesis
class
so
if we're looking at the probability that
we transition to say x prime given that
we're in say x and take action a we're
saying this looks like the dot product
of our feature map fee
and another feature map mu
of x prime
um now so in this setting we're assuming
fee is known but we're going to allow mu
to be unknown so this is still going to
be a learning problem
but
even though it's known
or even though it's unknown there's
still like limits the complexity of our
like our dynamics or our system so if
we're thinking of like p of x prime
given xa as a big matrix
um this is saying it has rank at most d
um and i'll just mention you know a good
property to keep in mind here is this
low rank mvp
property this implies that q star is
linear in fee so it implies
realizability but it's actually stronger
in the sense that it implies that all
policies
have linear q functions
any questions about this assumption
all right
so i'm going to describe an algorithm
for this low rank mdp setting
this algorithm
is called lsvi ucb so lci stands for
least squares value iteration so
um and this is going to be an algorithm
which is
still based on the idea of optimism and
upper confidence bounds
so
the idea here and i'll walk through this
step by step
is
we're trying to compute
um an optimistic q function q bar that
upper bounds the optimal q function q
star everywhere but the main difference
between like this and the tabular rl
approach we saw earlier is um we're
going to
use least squares to incorporate a
function approximation
and so i'll walk through this step by
step so
um so first you know as before we're
going to set our optimistic q function q
bar to zero at big step h plus one
and then i'll describe
sort of how we step backwards assuming
that we already have like q bar h plus
one computed okay
so the first step is we're going to
solve this least squares problem with
all the data we've collected so far
um and this is saying find me a
parameter theta
which minimizes the squared error
between you know the linear function
induced by theta
and
the reward
at the current step
plus my optimistic q function q bar at
the next state
um this is a little complicated but it's
motivated by you know the bellman
equation so the idea is like suppose i
plugged q star h plus 1 into this
equation in the place of q bar
then
the bellman equation tells me that q
star is actually what will minimize this
squared error up to some like
statistical deviations okay so we're
just simulating development equation
all right and now once we have this
parameter theta
that solves these squares we're just
going to take q bar h to be the linear
function that theta induces and then
we're going to add a confidence bonus to
ensure that we're optimistic and i'll
say more about how we choose this
confidence bonus in a minute
um but that's basically it once we have
q bar we just pick the policy that
optimizes it
all right and what you can show is that
this method has regret as well as sample
complexity that's polynomial in the
dimension and the horizon and has no
dependence on the number of states so
you are in fact achieving exploration
generalization and credit assignment um
and this is also computationally
efficient which is nice
um so let me explain how these bonuses
work and kind of sketch the proof
so
you know just like the tabular setting
the crux of the analysis for this
algorithm will be to show that it's
optimistic so q bar upper bounds q star
everywhere
and to prove this i need to say what the
bonus we're adding to the the q
functions is and this is what we'll call
like an elliptic bonus
so
at episode t
we're going to let sigma
h
t
be the sum of the outer products for all
the feature vectors we've seen at step h
up until this point so this is something
like a second moment matrix to the
features
and we're going to set the bonus for xa
to be like the norm of the features for
xa but under this sort of like
re-weighted euclidean norm
induced by the second moment matrix so
this is we're just looking at the
quadratic form
uh of phi transpose sigma inverse phi
we're taking the square root
and so the fact that this bonus leads to
optimism this comes out of least squares
and it's related to this idea of
extrapolation and the point is like
because we're working with linear
hypotheses
sigma t captures how much effective data
we have in different directions so like
if i see um
a lot of data in one direction this
quadratic form
is going to be small in that direction
which reflects the fact that we're
confident
okay and i won't go into detail about
this but
once we have this optimistic q function
just like in the tabular case we'll be
able to use the optimism property to
show that our regret is dominated by the
sum of these bonuses
and so all the remains of this point is
to show
that the bonuses are small or they get
small
and this is going to use a potential
argument
that kind of generalizes what we saw in
the tabular setting and this again will
reflect our ability to extrapolate
so
let's look at the sum of the bonuses for
like step h within the episode
uh so the bonus for little episode t is
this quadratic form
of fee under the second moment matrix
sigma t
and the idea is well let's suppose this
bonus is big
this can really only happen if phi
for the state t at time t
um extends in a direction that's not
currently well covered by sigma t
but what's gonna happen is well when we
get to the next episode we're gonna add
this feature vector
to sigma t to get like you know sigma t
plus one so like the matrix for the next
time step and so the point is like okay
our coverage might be bad at this step
but it is going to improve at the next
step
um
and the good news is because we're in a
d dimensional space the effective number
of times we're gonna get surprised and
shrink if we use the strategy will be
proportional to d and so indeed you can
show that this sum of bonuses is going
to scale as like root dimension times t
okay um so so to summarize
this low rank mdp structure facilitates
sample efficient learning
with this mechanism of extrapolation
um and i'll briefly show now that we can
kind of extend this idea of
extrapolation slightly beyond linear
models using a property that's called
eluder dimension
so a lunar dimension
this is a combinatorial parameter
introduced by russo and van roy and it
kind of gives a handle on how much the
function class you're working with can
extrapolate i'll briefly define this
so a lunar dimension is saying
let's say i have a function class script
f
what is the longest sequence of points
uh z1 through zn
such that for each point zt in this
sequence there exists a pair of
functions in this class
that disagree on zt by epsilon
but if we look at their like root mean
squared error on all the points that
proceed it's at most epsilon
so this is asking you like in a pretty
literal sense
if i look at functions that are close in
squared error
how many times can i get surprised by
new points and this is pretty natural if
you work with algorithms based on least
squares like the lsvi method we just saw
so a lunar dimension means
i cannot get many
surprised many times at a given scale
before i stop making mistakes
and so indeed like what russo and van
roy showed is like for bandits
you can get uh you know regret
proportional to a lunar dimension um i'm
being imprecise about the dependence on
epsilon here but it's
mild um
and so this is for bandits and it's
reflecting the fact that you're able to
generalize across actions there's no
states
but and but there's more recent work
that shows that algorithms in the vein
of like the lsvi ucv method we just saw
can get regret that's polynomial in the
eluder dimension of the value function
class once i do reinforcement learning
um this does require additional
assumptions because uh like these are
kind of in the vein of like the low rank
mdp assumption so like
low alluded dimension on its own is not
enough
um
what's up
or was there a question yeah uh just
understand a little bit what is the
domain of all these functions um
because if if for example we are
continuous i can assume that the
eluter dimension is infinite
yeah it can be infinite it's not always
small
so actually let me give some examples
okay but just to be clear like when we
apply this to rl
we're doing we're applying this to like
a class of q functions so the domain
will be like states by actions
but yes it's not hard to construct
examples where this is infinite indeed
so like if we look at some examples um
for linear models you know you can show
that this is bounded by the feature
dimension
um and this is also true for generalized
linear models you know for example if
you have a linear model and then you
just apply some non-linear link to it
like sigmoid
but
you can actually show like even just for
like a single relu neuron
uh the lunar dimension can be
exponential in the feature dimension and
indeed there are other examples where
it's just infinite so morally you know
you should think of eluder dimension as
like a slight generalization of
linearity and i have to say it kind of
remains to be seen whether there are
like natural rl settings where lunar
dimension is actually necessary and not
just sufficient to
get low sample complexity but this is
just sort of a consequence of the fact
that
you know extrapolation
is something that you can't really do
when you go beyond like far beyond like
linear models
okay and so you know
with that in mind what we're gonna look
at now is the other approach to handling
distribution shift i described which is
you know how can we control the number
of effective state distributions that we
encounter
so
the way we're going to do this is using
a notion which is called bellman rink
so
to motivate bill and rank i'm going to
come back to this low rank mdp setting
briefly
um and we're going to make the following
observation which is
uh if we you know so again just to recap
this is again we're assuming p
factorizes into phi dot product mu
so
what we can use the low rank mdp
structure to show is
if i have just like say some function f
of x
and i have some policy pi
i can write the expected value of f of
xh for any h
under
uh policy pi so like when i'm selecting
my actions with pi
i can write this as the dot product of a
vector x
that depends on pi but not on
the function f
and a vector w of f
which is going to depend on the function
f i'm looking at
but not on the policy pi so this we this
factorization as like a function of the
policy and a function of the
well the
vector that depends on the policy a
vector that depends on the function i'm
looking at
so the idea behind bellman rank is
there are certain functions where it's
really useful to have this factorization
property and these are what we'll call
bellman residuals
so
formally the bellman residual is going
to be a function that depends on a
policy pi that i kind of roll in with
and a value function q that i'm
considering and this is just
the difference between the q function at
step h
and the reward at step h
plus
uh the q function except h plus one
so let you know that that that's this
this funny i'm looking at but we're
taking the expectation of this
under a process where we follow policy
pi until time h
and then
choose the action that the policy
induced by q wants to take
once we get to time h
um so why is this an interesting
quantity to care about
again this is motivated by the bellman
equation
so if we look at
the bellman residual for q star
the bellman equation tells us this is
zero regardless of what policy we roll
in with like what policy we play up to
time h
um and so evaluating this residual will
give us a way of ruling out bad q
functions that don't satisfy the bellman
equation
um so returning to the linear mdp
if you use the property i i sort of
sketched above
we'll be able to show that uh the
bellman residual factorizes into a dot
product of
again
a vector that depends on pi but not q
and a vector that depends on q but not
pi
so in other words if we look at this
bellman residual as a big matrix
index by policies and q functions this
is saying the rank of this matrix is at
most d
and belm rank is just a generalization
of this property it's just asking okay
interpret the residual as a big matrix
what is the rank of this thing um
so let me explain exactly what this sort
of assumption buys us statistically
well what you can show is like whenever
you have a realizable class of q
functions containing q star
you can learn a near optimal policy with
sample complexity that's polynomial in
the bell and rank
um in the number of actions
and the horizon and most importantly in
like the statistical capacity of your
your class of q functions
um and the first thing to focus on here
is this statistical complexity comp of
script q this is exactly what we want
this is like a standard generalization
error from statistical learning like
think log cardinality of your function
class for finite classes
i'll just make a couple more remarks so
one is
the bound i stated here this depends on
the number of actions
there are other
variants of this property that allow you
to generalize across actions
so as well so you can actually remove
the number of actions in your band in
this case
um the other point i'll say is like
unlike all the settings we've looked at
so far we actually don't have
computationally efficient algorithms for
low bell and rank in general
and there are some very interesting open
questions here
okay so i'm going to describe an
algorithm that achieves the sample
complexity guarantee
um
this is an algorithm which is called
bilin ucb
um and this is a variant of another
algorithm called olive which was the
sort of first algorithm for this setting
um bilin ucb
like most of the algorithms we've seen
up to this point is based on the notion
of optimism
and the name is coming from the fact
that when we assume
uh low bell and rink our bellman
residuals have this bilin bilinear
structure you know so bilingual okay
um
and so this algorithm is kind of based
on what are called confidence sets so at
each episode t or each iteration we're
gonna have this confidence set which we
call script q superscript t
this is going to be a subset of all the
q functions in our hypothesis class and
the point will be that we'll gradually
shrink this as we get rid of bad q
functions so let's walk through the
steps um the first step will be
we're going to find what we'll call an
optimistic q function q bar t
um
the way we're going to do this is a
little different from the other
approaches we've seen so far we won't
necessarily be working with bonuses
instead
we're going to define a function which
is called jq of pi
and this is the expected value of q1
under the initial state distribution
where we're selecting actions with pi
and you can think of this as like an
estimate for the average reward of pi
according to q
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to pick uh q bar t to be the
function in our confidence set that
maximizes j q of pi q so you can
interpret this as saying find the
surviving q function that thinks most
highly of itself um
it could be wrong though so we need to
make sure you know uh we need to make
sure we take care of that but once we
have uh cube rt as usual we're going to
take pi t to be the the greedy policy
for q bar t so just the the policy that
maximizes qrt
um and then there's two more steps
so
the first step i won't go into detail
about how we do this but the idea is
by running pi t for a small number of
episodes we'll be able to get an
estimate for the bellman residual
under pi t
that's close for all the q functions in
our q function class
and then the way we're going to update
our confidence set
is
by keeping only the q functions
where the sum of squared residuals that
we've estimated so far is small oh sorry
about this there's a typo here so these
the bellman script e in this definition
should have a square on it okay
so we're just keeping the q functions
where the sum of bell residual squared
is small the motivation being
we know that q star has zero bound
residual up to some small statistical
error
okay but to summarize each iteration of
this method is going to have sample
complexity that's polynomial in all the
parameters we care about
so we just need to control how many
iterations this takes before we get a
good optimal before we have an optimal
policy or like you know before regret
starts shrinking
okay and i'll quickly walk through the
analysis here
um so just for reference at the top here
again i'm just displaying the definition
of the bellman residual and we'll recall
that this factorizes into this x of pi
component and this w of q component in d
dimensions that's by assumption
so
the first step in this analysis is to
show that q star is never eliminated so
q star always stays in our confidence
set um and this is pretty natural again
this just follows from the bellman
equation which says that q star
has zero bell and residual for any
policy
okay
and as a result of this property we'll
be able to show that q bar is optimistic
although in a slightly different sense
than what we've seen so far so it's kind
of optimistic on average what i mean by
this is that this quantity j q bar t of
pi t which we said is what q bar thinks
its average reward is this upper bounds
the optimal reward
okay now the next step is
using kind of like a telescoping
argument
you can actually show that for any queue
function
the difference between
what it thinks its average reward is
and the actual average reward of the
induced policy
this is bounded by the sum of bellman
residuals
which if we use the bell and rank
property you know is the sum of dot
products of
factors that depend on pi
factors that depend on cube
and in particular if you combine this
with optimism
you can show that like the
sub-optimality of the policies selected
by this algorithm is bounded by the
residuals
by these bellman rank kind of factors
where we're taking the dot product of
this factor that depends on the policy
we play and this factor that depends on
cube rt
okay and finally
the idea is
because we defined this confidence set
in terms of the bellman residuals from
past rounds which also have this
bilinear structure we're going to be
able to bound
this
error in the residual as
you know um
sort of like
this weighted euclidean norm very
similar to what we were looking at for
the low rank mdp setting so this is a
norm that's defined based on all of the
x components for our bellman rink
factorization that we've seen so far
and again this is going to quantify
what are the effective directions in
which we've seen a lot of data so far
but in a kind of
more problem-dependent sense than in the
low rank mdp setting what i mean by that
is
we only care about directions we've seen
data
kind of projected on to these bellman
residuals
so the point though is
using the same sort of potential style
argument i sketched for the low rank
mdps you can show that these norms go to
zero at a rate that's proportional to
the bellman rink and that's kind of it
okay are there any questions on this
before i move on and look at some
examples
all right
uh yeah so let let's make this a little
more concrete so we'll just walk through
some some settings that have low belmont
rank this is maybe a little related to
bacillus's question earlier
um the first couple of these we can
check out are just you know we can
verify that for the for the tabular
setting like finite states and actions
you can always bound to the bell and
rank by the number of states which is a
good sanity check
and likewise as we saw for low rank mdps
the bell rank is always linear in the
feature dimension um another
example which will be familiar if you're
coming from like the control theory side
is
if you look at like the linear quadratic
regulator this is sort of the canonical
optimal linear control problem where we
have
continuous states and actions
and you can show that the bellman rank
for this setup scales just with like the
state dimension in the action dimension
all right um there's many other examples
you can consider one that i want to
focus on is what's called the block mdp
so the block mdp is a model that's
trying to capture
uh how can we do sample efficient
learning when we have rich observations
so like the setup is i have like a large
high dimensional state space but we
assume these states can be uniquely
mapped down into a small unobserved
latent state space that is responsible
for determining the dynamics like
the motivation being
if we're trying to play a game like
atari our states might be images of the
game which we can represent as raw
pixels and these are very high
dimensional but the underlying game
state like if we think of
you know maybe the coordinates of our
paddle if we're playing pong
this is pretty simple and low
dimensional by comparison
and so we can model this by you know
assuming that the latent state space is
finite
and that means that if we could observe
the latent state space directly we could
just use like tabular reinforcement
learning to solve the problem
but the catch is we don't know the
latent states and we also don't know
what the mapping from observations to
latency is so we need to use you know
modeling and function approximation to
learn this
um and so what you can show for this
setting is
uh the bell in rank here actually only
depends on the number of latent states
and this means you can get sample
complexity that depends uh only on the
number of latent states and actions not
on the number of observed states so the
only catch is
you need your q function class to be
realizable so like to contain q star
um and this means like your q functions
need to be flexible enough to
represent this mapping from observations
to latent states so that's the kind of
way the modeling will come in here
um and i'll briefly just mention
the way you prove that the vellum rank
is bounded by s here is just by writing
development residual as a
sum of probabilities
uh for visiting each of the latent
states times
bell and residual conditioned on the
latent state and because there's only
like you know cardinality of script s
latent states you can write this as a
dot product in like s dimensions
okay
um i'll touch on one more example and
that's just if we come back to this low
rank mdp setting
you know we use the low rank mdp
structure here to show that
the the bell and rank was at most d
because we can write it as you know this
product of these two d dimensional
factors but the point i want to
highlight is that like
when we originally looked at the low
rank mdp setting we were assuming that
this feature map fee was known but this
argument that we have low bell and rank
here this actually works even if fee is
unknown and so this implies that you can
do sample efficient rl in low rank mvps
even if you don't know the features
um and the only catch is just
just like in the block mvp setting
you'll need a bigger q function class
skip q to represent the unknown features
if you want to satisfy realizability
i'll just do a little more discussion of
the low rank mdps
so first of all
the methods we've looked at
for uh you know for bell and rank so far
these have been value based like our
hypothesis class was a set of q
functions
there are some mdps
where modeling the q functions requires
high sample complexity but you can get
low sample complexity if you model the
transition probabilities directly so you
take a model based approach
and there's a variant of bellman rank
called witness rank that handles some of
these cases
also just mention there are other
kind of more general assumptions you can
make on how the bellman residuals
factorize these can also lead to tighter
guarantees in certain settings
and so if you take these into account
you know uh the the full landscape we'll
get will look something like this so we
have like witness rank this model based
property is allowing us to extend beyond
bell and rank
but the natural question you might be
wondering at this point is like what is
the true shape of this landscape like
i've given all these conditions that i
said are sufficient
to derive
sample efficient reinforcement learning
algorithms but like what about necessary
conditions so uh where does this green
tractable portion of the landscape end
so the last thing i'm going to go over
is a very recent result um and this is
like we have a new complexity measure uh
that
does exactly this so it's called the
decision estimation coefficient and it
gives necessary
uh conditions for sample efficient rl as
well as actually sufficient conditions
so
the decision estimation coefficient
this is a complexity measure that's
going to be defined in a model based
setting where we're
modeling transition probabilities or
like our hypothesis class is just a set
of mdps
so each mdp in this class has its own
probabilities and rewards associated
with it
and just like we've been doing for the
other rl settings we'll make a
realizability assumption and it should
assume that the true mdp m star is
contained in this class now i just need
to give a little bit more notation here
um
so for a given mdp in the class we are
going to let m of pi
denote the distribution over
trajectories that we get if we run
policy pi in the mdp
we're going to let jm of pi denote the
expected reward for pi if we run it in
the mdpm
and we're going to let pi star m denote
the optimal policy for the mdpm
so
okay so with these out of the way i can
define this complexity measure
uh
i'll walk through this step by step
because there's a lot going on but this
is a complexity measure which we're
denoting like dec
and this has three parameters so it
depends on this model class script m
it depends on what we'll call a
reference mdp which we're denoting m bar
and then it depends on a scale parameter
that we'll call uh gamma
um and so let me walk through this full
expression so
this decision estimation coefficient
this dec
this is
the value of a min max game so that's
actually in line with the theme of this
program um
where we're trying to find a
distribution over policies
for the learner so this is represented
by the min player
um
such that for a worst-case mdp in our
class which is represented by the max
player
um
if we look at the expected value of a
policy sampled from the learner's
distribution
um
we are looking at the difference between
uh the sub-optimality or like the regret
of their decision which i'm highlighting
here
and we want this to be controlled by the
estimation
relative
to the reference model m bar so here
when i say estimation error
we're looking at like hellinger distance
which is a distance metric between it's
a distance between distributions
um and we're looking at the difference
between the distribution over data
induced by the policy we're selecting
between this worst case model m and the
reference model
m bar
um i'll just mention very briefly if
you're more familiar with kl divergence
you can substitute kl in for helenger
here the the difference is not very
important for this setting
okay
but so okay so i just said a lot about
this expression let me just summarize
what this is actually means conceptually
so conceptually the way you should think
about this is
mbar is a guess for like the true model
the true mdp
and this decision estimation coefficient
this dec this is asking like in a very
literal sense
what is the strategy for the learner
that achieves the best trade-off between
the regret of the policy they select and
the information that they acquire by
selecting this policy
um and they're doing this in the face of
an unknown environment
and then the scale parameter gamma here
is just controlling this trade-off this
trade-off between like regret and
information
um okay and i'll just
finish off this definition by saying
that what we really care about is like
the max of the value of this thing over
reference models mbar in our class
okay
that is the definition are the are there
any questions about the definition here
oh let me it looks like there's a
question in chat give me one second
um
where is oh chris is asking where is p
in the game
um p is right outside if you look at
this expectation right outside the
brackets here we're sampling the policy
from p
uh wait was there another question
okay cool cool great
okay
so
the reason
why we care about this parameter is this
gives a necessary condition for sample
efficient rl
so we can show the following lower bound
in terms of the dec
so for any class of model script m
there is some model in this class or
some mdp in this class
where
your regret for any algorithm
is going to scale as the min of two
quantities so one is this decision
estimation coefficient at scale gamma
times t
and the other is gamma itself
okay and then we're taking the worst
case value of gamma for this expression
so you know intuitively this says if the
dec is large your regret has to be large
but it's easiest to let just walk
through a couple examples that give a
sense for how this lower band behaves
so first of all
for the multi-armed bandit
you can show that the dec at scale gamma
is proportional to the number of actions
divided by gamma
so if you plug this into the lower bound
um your regret is lower bounded by you
know the the min of these two terms um a
t over gamma and gamma
and
the the optimal value of gamma here just
balances these and it gives you root a t
which is the the min max rate for this
setting so you're recovering like the
optimal lower bound
um another basic example is
you can show for the bellman rank
setting
that the dec
you know is lower bounded by the you
know the dimension
of your factorization again divided by
gamma so if you do the same calculation
here you get the regret is lower bounded
by root dimension times t okay
um and the both of these examples are
like statistically tractable settings
but the cool thing is that this can
recover impossibility results or
intractability results so
if we look at this setting i mentioned
before where we assume
q star is linear
in a feature map in d dimensions but but
nothing else
um here you can show that the
dec uh
is exponential in the feature dimension
so if you
uh plug that into your lower bound yeah
you see that the regret for any
algorithm has to be exponential and
you're recovering the fact that the
setting is not tractable
um the last thing i'll say about this
complexity measure is
i stated this kind of coming at it from
the perspective of lower bounds but this
is actually very easy to operationalize
and kind of make algorithmic so
we have an algorithm
based on this complexity measure which
is called estimation to decisions and
you could think of this as a
generalization of this like square cv
method that we saw for contextual
bandits
and i'll just quickly walk through this
so
the idea is
at each episode we're going to get some
estimate for the mdp
using our s some just some supervised
estimation algorithm like this could be
density estimation or something else
and it's going to give me this estimator
just based on all the the data i've
collected up to this point
then once you have this estimate
we're going to
find the distribution over policies that
like solves the min max problem that
defines the dec
when you have m hat t plugged in as your
reference distribution
so this is just you know before when i
defined the dec i i defined it as a min
max now we're just looking at the
argument for the exact same min max
and then once we get this distribution
over policies
we're just going to sample the policy to
play from this distribution
and then we'll
update our supervised estimation
algorithm with the data we see
um and so what you can show is that this
this strategy actually achieves a regret
bound that matches
the lower bound i showed on the previous
slide
up to the addition of an
uh extra term that kind of corresponds
to
how well is your supervised estimation
algorithm doing
so we have this term s sub h here this
is just the sum of hellinger distances
between
all the estimates that your your
supervised estimation algorithm has
produced and the the true model or true
mdp m star
um and this estimation here this is a
classical quantity so
um
you know this is something where you can
show
uh you know like if i look at say finite
classes this is like log cardinality of
the functioning class if you look at
parametric models this is going to scale
with the dimension and so the point is
this is achieving the same regret bound
as in the previous slide but the gamma
term is scaled by this estimation error
so conceptually this is saying as long
as this dec is small
and as long as you can estimate well you
can achieve low regret
and so in particular what this means is
for
classes of mdps where you have like
bounded supervised estimation complexity
the dec completely characterizes when
sample efficient learning is possible
um and i'll just mention
to tie this back again
the square cb method we saw for
contextual bandits like both the
algorithm and the analysis are actually
special cases of this result
one short question just understand
something
the min max problem
is easily solvable
uh that completely depends on the
structure of the problem yeah so i mean
in the general case could be non-complex
non-concave
right
or not oh good question um no so so it's
linear with respect to the the learner's
strategy
right
but so as far as they distribute
the uh how about the
the
m the
[Music]
uh
the space of the market yeah yeah yeah
so exactly so so that that's that's
where you kind of need to use additional
problem structure so like there's tons
of special cases where we know how to
solve this so like
essentially we know how to solve this
efficiently for
most of the settings i've covered in the
talk up to this point but there are many
open questions here and i can say more
about that offline yeah so yeah yeah
yeah
another question so
even though this has some information
there is sort of like spin is it is
there any relation with a rusev android
type of approach for multi-arm bandits
oh are you talking about the information
ratio yeah yeah yeah that's a great
question so yeah information ratio is
like a kind of it's another you could
kind of think of it as a complexity
measure for bandits um yeah so you can
actually show
that the this dec is always upper
bounded by the information ratio
uh in general though there are models
where like the dec is small and the
information ratio can be arbitrarily
large
um but there are actually some deeper
connections i can say more about that
offline as well
cool okay um we're coming towards the
end i'll just briefly summarize this
these approaches we saw to the rl
problem
and these are ways of attacking
distribution shifts so on one hand we
saw that we can attack the problem using
the idea of extrapolation using you know
say like linear models in low-rank mdps
and using a lunar dimension and on the
other hand we saw you can try to control
the effective number of distributions
using notions like uh bellman rank and
then finally this decision estimation
coefficient
this acts as a converse and it provides
necessary rather than just sufficient
conditions for sample efficient learning
in rl
and that's going to bring me actually to
the end of the tutorial
so
just to come back to the broader message
we saw these three challenges we saw
exploration we saw generalization we saw
credit assignments we saw you know that
we have
classical solutions to these individual
challenges as well as solutions when we
pair them
and really the frontier of theoretical
rl is trying to put them all together
like exploring with a long horizon while
we generalize across states
this is a problem where we have to make
modeling assumptions to get sample
efficient learning guarantees we saw a
bunch of different ways of doing this
but there are a ton of open questions
and this is really like an active line
of research
i think on one hand
a lot of research required to come up
with new models that kind of better
capture considerations of
real world rl problems you know beyond
like many of the idealized settings
we've seen so far um and i think you
know with some of these new tools we've
gotten over the last couple years we're
in a much better place to do this than
maybe we were in the past
i'm gonna also say you know while our
understanding on the statistical side
is kind of starting to take shape
uh
computation and like computational
efficiency you know is a place where
there's still a lot to be done even just
for the settings i discussed today
okay and lastly i'll just give a little
bit more of a
teaser for like cheese tutorial later in
the afternoon right so the point of this
is going to be
how does everything i i talked about
today change once we have an mdp that
kind of has like multiple agents
operating in it either like in
cooperation or adversarially and and
this raises
some cool issues right so you know we
can think about
i talked a lot about function
approximation modeling today how does
this change once you know i have say
like an opponent like what do i need to
be able to model about what my opponent
is doing
or you know
we looked at you know this optimization
perspective on rl in the first part of
the tutorial once we go to multi-agent
rl that becomes something maybe close to
a min max optimization perspective right
so this is also very much uh
along the lines of the theme of this uh
workshop and program
so those are just a couple questions uh
there's many more but i think it should
be a lot of fun and i'm looking forward
to it
so yeah with that i can stop and take
questions
thank you very much dylan yep this was
an excellent tutorial
questions
[Music]
oh hey yeah uh i want to ask about so i
think um in major part of this stuff we
are talking about like how people make
assumptions on the complexity
of this ring for uh
making some like complexity assumption
on this entire reinforced learning
procedure
i want to say like how robust
is it for practice
and i think in general in practice
people are just
using something like single like for
example have some greedy or something
sure
what's the major gap between this theory
and practice
yeah so i guess the thing is
okay there's a couple questions there
right
the thing is like these epsilon greedy
approaches right like
so a lot of what i talked about today
was really trying to understand how to
do like exploration like how did you how
to systematically explore because like
in the worst case things like epsilon
greedy
these don't systematically explore and
they can have you know sample complexity
like let's say like exponential in the
horizon now
if you're trying to solve some
you know real world problem
it depends on how you're trying to solve
it so if you have like a simulator or
something where you can just get tons
and tons and tons and tons of data like
billions of rounds of interaction you
can potentially overcome this and that's
especially true you know or so i should
say overcome this without systematically
exploring and that's especially true if
you have kind of like a nice mdp that uh
you know
maybe is not worst case right
um but i think like understanding these
issues of like how do we combine
exploration this is going to be
important as we move into problems that
have like longer horizon or where we
maybe have like less data available like
where sample efficiency becomes like a
real concern so that's kind of like the
motivation okay
um
oh yeah you said how robust are these
things
uh that's a good question so like most
of the methods i talked about today you
know are gonna make some assumption like
realizability
and pretty much all of them are gonna
degrade in like a
reasonable fashion if this like
realizability only holds like let's say
like epsilon approximately but
the real question is like well does this
realizability hold epsilon approximately
to begin with and i think
if we go to settings like where you
really have continuous state and action
spaces it's not clear that any of the
models we have yet are like a really
great fit for this or give something
that you can actually try running yet so
that's that's an area where i think
there's a lot more to explore
um oh it looks like there's a question
from costas in the chat
um oh yeah costus is asking there's some
contention between the structure and the
mdp like the realizability assumption
and
uh which necessitates a rich class of
models
any thoughts on non-realizable settings
that's an interesting question right so
you can think about agnostic versions of
rl you can think about like settings
where i just say uh maybe i just start
off with some small class of policies
and i want to compete with the best in
class um
unfortunately you can show that like
being agnostic is not really possible in
a sample efficient manner
without further assumptions
um
and so for example like you know you can
come up with settings where i have a
very small hypothesis class like maybe
only two hypotheses that i care about
but
i still need like exponential sample
complexity to figure out which one is
which so like just the fact that i'm
trying to be agnostic doesn't help me
much
um
and the interesting thing is like
so so basically you still need to make
modeling assumptions but like i i do
think that this being like
semi-agnostic is interesting to explore
um
there are some very concrete questions
there that i've been thinking about and
i think we're actually in a pretty good
position to attack this problem with
some of this machinery we've developed
for like this the dec that i was just
talking about
great so let's end here uh there's gonna
be a two hour break not to our break
we're gonna be back at two
uh for two uh jeans tutorial and
multi-agent rl and thank you again
dillon for this wonderful tutorial
thanks a lot and thanks for coming
everyone
so hopefully we'll get to hang out more
in you know the near future